-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Former president Trump
pleaded not guilty yesterday
to 34 charges of
falsifying business records.
Well, his voice pleaded
not guilty.
His face pleaded
guilty as hell.
[ Laughter ]
Former president Trump
spoke last night
at Mar-a-Lago
following his arraignment
and said, "I never
thought anything like this
could happen in America."
Honestly, neither did I.
I mean, you got away with
so many crimes for so long.
Trump getting arrested
was like "Avatar 2."
I just figured it was
never going to happen.
Then it finally did,
and I was like,
you know what? Worth the wait.
[ Laughter ]
In his speech at Mar-a-Lago
last night
after his arraignment,
former president Trump
thanked his family
and said,
"I have a great family
and they've done a fantastic job
and we appreciate it very much."
Great that he likes his family.
But why does he talk about them
the way a high school principal
talks about the prom committee?
They've done a great job.
We really appreciate them.
And, you know, it looks like
we're under the sea.
Give them a hand.
Eric Trump retweeted a photo
of former president Trump
in court yesterday
with the caption, "Boss!"
No, dude, it's your father.
What?
[ Laughter ]
What is wrong
with this family?
After former president Trump's
post-arraignment event
at Mar-a-Lago last night,
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene said that
Trump was "committed like
she's never seen him before."
Well, yeah, but that's
a pretty low benchmark.
If he was committed before,
he wouldn't be in this mess
to begin with.
[ Laughter ]
Fox News chairman
Rupert Murdoch has reportedly
called off his engagement.
And just as his leg was healing
from getting down on one knee.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. 92-year-old
Fox News chairman
Rupert Murdoch has reportedly
called off his engagement.
Yeah, don't rush into anything.
You've got your whole month
ahead of you.
[ Laughter ]
Lawmakers in Texas
are considering two new bills
that would allow firearm safety
to be taught in high school
and, if there's money
left over, math.
[ Laughter ]